sie schränken geldautomaten in ganz
deutschland jetzt hat die polizei in den
niederlanden neun männer festgenommen
ins rollen gekommen waren die
ermittlungen vor anderthalb jahren weil
ein 29 jähriger niederländer bei einer
firma fünf geldautomaten bestellt hatte
angeblich für ein kunstprojekt ja
wirklich dumme idee denn dadurch wurde
die polizei erst auf sie aufmerksam aber
warum wollten die automaten acker
überhaupt lehre geldautomaten kaufen die
sie tatsächlich unter den augen der
polizei auch erhielten ganz einfach sie
wollten damit das sprengen
unter den fünf automaten war auch dieses
gerät vom typ progress 2000 der firma
wincor nixdorf bei automatenknacker war
es zeitweilig besonders beliebt wurde
aber angeblich inzwischen vom hersteller
nachgebessert die spreng übungen
verliefen wohl aber nur mäßig
erfolgreich um nicht zu sagen tragisch
der 29 jährige der die automaten
bestellt hatte kam bei dem versuch ums
leben ja zugeschlagen hat die bande an
zahlreichen orten in deutschland
insgesamt 15 tatorte konnten ihn
eindeutig zugeordnet werden wie unsere
karte auch zeigt
und wie so was dann aussieht zeigt ein
fall der im september in unserer bild tv
sendung achtung verhandlungen hatten
tatort war ratingen hier hatten anwohner
den versuch von gangstern gefilmt eine
bank automatisch zu sprengen dabei kamen
gleich zwei sprengsätze marke eigenbau
zum einsatz
thomassen fast noch heftiger diese
bilder aus monheim aus dem jahr 2018
damals führten die täter den
geldautomaten mit einem gas luft gemisch
dann wurde mit spiritus eine art
zündschnur gelegt brandgefährlich
natürlich nicht nur für die täter und
leider schon fast ein massendelikt nach
angaben des bka flogen allein im
vergangenen jahr deutschlandweit 414
geldautomaten in die luft das sind 18
prozent mehr als noch 2009 10 der
schaden belief sich auf rund 17
millionen euro
kommen wir zurück zum aktuellen fall der
aufgeflogene bande in holland und
zugeschaltet ist jetzt marco eller man
von der polizeidirektion ost rückkehrer
man die ermittlungen haben sicher lange
gestreckt warum hat es so lange gedauert
bis die niederländischen
niederländischen kollegen zu schlagen
konnten der gute morgen nach berlin also
das kann man ganz klar und einfach
beantworten wir haben es hier nicht mit
kleinen kriminellen zu tun sondern mit
profis und profis arbeit entsprechend
arbeitsteilig organisiert
länderübergreifend und mobil und
deswegen dauern solche ermittlungen
natürlich auch in kombination mit
anderen ländern länger als bei kleineren
delikten hellermann dass sich die
gangster automaten zu üben besorgen ist
das ungewöhnlich
also das zeugt schon von
professionalität und wir reden jetzt
auch von organisierter kriminalität bei
dieser geschichte also von daher ist das
hochprofessionell die testlabore in den
niederlanden habe stillgelegt und
festgestellt das war schon was
einmaliges das gab es in der form nicht
zeigt uns aber eben dass die
organisierte kriminalität sehr
professionell strukturiert ist wir sind
denn die täter in den aktuellen fällen
genau vorgegangen
wir müssen sich vorstellen arbeitsteilig
hat jeder seine aufgaben der einen sorgt
für den sprengstoff der andere bei lofer
die taten aus wo sind die automaten
entsprechend anfällig der andere sorgt
sich eben auch um die anmietung der
fahrzeuge welche fahrzeuge werden
genommen unter umständen auch garagen
die angemietet werden um eben auch
geschluckt nicht direkt zu
nachvollziehen sondern eben auch erstmal
sich unterzutauchen dann sozusagen in
einer garage es ist sehr arbeitsteilig
vorgegangen jeder hat seine aufgabe
welche sprengmittel setzten die täter
bevorzugt mittlerweile ein
in den letzten jahren war es zunehmend
gasgemische jetzt haben wir aber auch
festgestellt dass fest sprengstoff also
richtiger echten sprengstoff verwandt
wird was natürlich auch sehr gefährlich
ist für unbeteiligte auch für die
polizisten und rettungskräfte vor ort
wir haben einen schritt auch einen fall
gehabt dass das haus abgebrannt eine
familie ist mit der drehleiter gerettet
worden kurz vor knapp wenn sie so wollen
also es ist hochgefährlich und da müssen
wir jetzt endlich auch an wir wissen
natürlich auch dass der sprengstoff auch
durch hintermänner organisiert wird und
da laufen die ermittlungen um zu schauen
wer es da noch mit dem boot das sei ein
großer erfolg
trotzdem es kommt immer wieder vor warum
ist es eigentlich so schwierig diesen
tätern das handwerk zu legen
weil sie eben sehr konspirativ arbeiten
sie versuchen natürlich auch die polizei
und die strafverfolgungsbehörden
auszutricksen sie sind sehr verdeckt
unterwegs sie sind ich sagte dass
bereits arbeitsteiligen unterwegs und
sie machen und tun letztendlich alles
damit die polizei eben nicht auf die
schliche kommt und das macht es eben
auch so schwer und deswegen ist es eben
auch wichtig dass wir europäische
polizeilich und auch bei der justiz
zusammenarbeiten und das hat dieser
erfolg eindrucksvoll gezeigt marco
ellermann besten dank für die
einordnungen und wir gehen weiter zu
unserem reporter frank schneider bild
chef in nordrhein westfalen der sich
schon seit langem mit diesen gangstern
beschäftigt mit diesen automatenknacker
frank warum kommen eigentlich die
meisten immer wieder aus den
niederlanden
ja die kommen aus den niederlanden aber
eigentlich sind es gar keine
niederländer es handelt sich hier in der
hauptsache um noch afrikaner und da
nochmal ganz großen anteil fast über 80%
marokkaner und das sind großfamilien wir
kennen das ja hier mit der
kleinkriminalität und hier sind es eine
hauptsache libanesen in holland sind es
eben nordafrikaner und der handel
sicherung einen plan in größe von drei
bis vierhundert personen die in
verschiedenen beteiligungen immer wieder
an diesen taten beteiligt sind und das
ist das große problem holland liegt nun
mal direkt neben deutschland wir wollen
haben das problem früh erkannt dort
wurden banken nachgerüstet dort wurden
die automaten nachgerüstet auch die
polizei hat die hauptaugenmerk eben auf
diese täter gerichtet naja und dann ist
man eben einfach über die grenze
gefahren und hat diese daten dann in
deutschland verübt mit dem traurigen
höhepunkt letztes jahr so viele daten
wie vorher noch nie du sagst es gerade
in ganz deutschland aber vor allem geht
es ja auch um nrw weil es so dicht an
holland liegt absolut das sind die
fluchtwege
die täter sind ja über lange zeit immer
mit hochmotorisierten fahrzeugen lange
zeit mit audi insbesondere mit dem rs6
abgehauen sind teils mit 250 über die
autobahn geflüchtet auch völlig ohne
rücksicht auf verluste auch auf eigene
verluste ist hat auch tote gegeben den
täter fahrzeugen immer wieder bei
unfällen und dann die haben eben von
polizeisprecher schon gehört ist man
auch da flexibel geworden und hat dann
angefangen garagen anzubieten ist erst
mal sozusagen in einer garage gefahren
hat sich dort ein zwei teile auf
gehalten ist dann erst weiter geflüchtet
oder wie trojanische pferde man hat er
mit motorrollern plötzlich die flucht
begangen also mit ganz niedrig
motorisierten fahrzeugen ist aber in
lkws oder lieferwagen damit eingefahren
drei straßen weiter hat dann im
lieferwagen erstmal abgewartet und ist
mit damit dem unauffälligen lieferwagen
zurück nach holland gefahren aber die
polizei hat das natürlich nach und nach
dann eben auch gemerkt weil man ja immer
wieder täter bekommen hat das große
problem ist nur das ist wie so eine
krake man steckt ein paar köpfe ab und
es wachsen immer wieder neuen nach in
diesem clan strukturen auch dann online
wir kennen das von ihr ist es für junge
männer eben total attraktiv damit
reinzuwachsen man muss ja überlegen die
beutel ist gigantisch wir holen
teilweise aus so einem geldautomaten bis
zu einer halben million raus man denkt
ja immer da kann ja gar nicht so viel
drin sein aber die werden bestimmt mit
200 bis zu
700.000 euro da kann man sich vorstellen
wenn man eine bank vorhaben sogar
manchmal zwei springen das schaffen die
ja auch wenn die beute meist mal bei
einer million jetzt haben wir auch eben
gehört es wird immer mehr sprengstoff
eingesetzt wie gefährlich ist das für
die täter natürlich aber auch für die
menschen die in unmittelbarer nähe
wohnen ja das ist natürlich extrem
gefährlich besonders weil wir haben ja
gesehen der haupttäter ist ja selber
weiterhin sind probe sprengungen ums
leben gekommen und ich meine ernährung
muss ja eigentlich wissen was er da tut
und wenn das risiko selbst für ihn so
hoch war dass er ums leben gekommen ist
zeigt das ja auch das ist unkalkulierbar
ist die haben lange zeit nicht gas und
luft gemische agiert und das haben sie
am ende so professionell gemacht dass
sie teilweise ein bisschen sarkastisch
auch geringere strafen bekam vor gericht
weil die richter sagt na ja wir haben
das so dosiert eingesetzt die gebäude
stellen die hand als gigantisch waren da
sind manchmal ganze häuser in die luft
geflogen das war am ende überhaupt nicht
mehr zu denn für die täter war es ja
auch wichtig dass das geld nicht
beschädigt werde man hat am ende so
dosiert gearbeitet dass die schäden an
den gebäuden sehr gering war jetzt
agiert man erneut mit sprengstoff weil
natürlich die automaten nachgerüstet
wurden die haben gassensoren sobald gas
eingeleitet wird machen sie sozusagen zu
es wird nebel eingeleitet in den bank
vorraum und die polizei dann automatisch
wissen die täter und jetzt agieren sie
neuerdings mit selbstlaborate mit
sprengstoff und da sind die folgen geben
überhaupt nicht zu ermessen des wegen
verdienen diese täter die man jetzt
gefasst hat auch wegen versuchten mordes
ermittelt bei dem haus in schüttorf aus
der polizeisprecher eben erwähnte passt
eine familie mit einem siebenjährigen
kind ums leben gekommen wäre und das
zeigt diese unglaubliche gefahr für alle
menschen die in einem haus leben wo eine
band drin ist in einem nachbarhaus das
sind unkalkulierbare risiken aber die
täter höheren schlicht einfach nicht auf
und sie werden auch jetzt nicht aufhören
es ist eine tätergruppierung ausgehoben
man hat sicherlich auch erstmal einen
schlag geschafft gegen diese probieren
aber es wird nicht aufhören sie leben
alle im bereich amsterdam utrecht das
sind in vorstädten dem ganze straßenzüge
in der hand dieser clans und ich kann
mir überhaupt nicht vorstellen dass wir
in den nächsten wochen deshalb weniger
sprengstoffanschläge sozusagen auf
bankautomaten erleben franke erklären
noch mal bitte ganz kurz warum lohnt
sich das überhaupt das sind doch
farbpatronen in diesem geldautomaten die
dann bei einer sprengung in die luft
gehen und das geld doch eigentlich
unbrauchbar machen ja das ist genau der
grund es wird nochmals mit farbe
unbrauchbar gemacht aber durch diesen
sprengstoff sind teilweise diese
kartuschen dann auch beschädigt und
können das geld nicht nur um auch bei
machen die gehen aber dieses risiko
einfach schlicht ein wenn das geld
unbrauchbar ist da kommen sie über eine
woche später wieder und man kann sie
einfach nicht nur den griff bekommen
wenn man wenn man sie fast aber das ist
so eine große gruppe ist und wie ich
beschrieben aber immer wieder junge
leute nachweis dass es attraktiv das
sehen sie als eine art beruf wird glaube
ich dieses problem kaum in den griff zu
bekommen seien und die polizei eine
wurst ist auch selbst wenn die automaten
immer sicher und das geld um bauweise
dann wird diese riesen der op und sich
auf andere dinge spezialisiert die sind
absolut kalt und ich gewalttätig und
dann ist die frage was machen sie dann
[Musik]